Any suggested help for chronic diarrhea,
meaning often starting several times daily and lasting for several sequential days,
and sometimes weeks at times, a few days break,
and then skin out again for a lengthy time period.
And while the diarrhea is occurring,
what are possibly the nutritional deficiencies that it may cause.
Thank you.
So, you could say, oh, what's the help with chronic diarrhea?
Well, first again, with anything you have a symptom,
you have a side objective finding this symptom that you're experiencing.
You've got to find out why.
So why do you have this?
What is the reason I would do a stool test?
So I would do a cup of heads of stool analysis.
That would be a first step.
You have to find out if you have parasites,
you have to find out if you have H. Pylori,
which is a bacterial infection, very, very common.
Your microbiome might be totally messed up
just from the diarrhea itself.
It's going to mess it up.
What other deficiencies could you have with this?
Well, anything because if you don't keep it food,
and you log it up to absorb your nutrients,
you could be deficient in all sorts of nutrients.
Certainly, you could be, you know,
deficient did just fluid in water.
So you could have dehydration type symptoms too.
You got to get to the bottom of this.
This is not normal.
This is not healthy. It's not good.
Getting a cup of heads of food stool sample test
is what I would start with.
I don't know who asked this question,
but if you want to work with us,
you need to schedule a case review
and then you can order that.
We can order that test.
You got to get to the reason why,
with anything you're going on,
you want to find out why.
You don't want to just, oh, we'll just start taking this.
So we'll just start doing this.
So we're going to start doing this.
Because then you could actually mask the problem.
That's not good.
So that's, that's the problem I have with so many medications.
So we're just going to start taking the modium
because I have chronic diarrhea.
We have chronic diarrhea for a reason.
So your, your body's trying to expel something.
You know, what is the abnormality going on?
Could be something as simple as a stock,
or a sickle valve to something as,
you know, bad as a complete imbalance.
It got microbiota, paracetic function,
H. Pylori, other bacterial involvement.
You got to get to the root of this and fix this.
Could be something as serious as cancer or something too.
So it's not something just to,
that's why I think it's a mistake just to,
to mask symptoms,
whether you use herbs to mask symptoms,
vitamins to mask symptoms.
Or, or using a medication.
What, what's the difference you do?
Are you still masking the symptoms or doing it in a natural way?
Okay, it's, it's just, it's bad.
So it's just as wrong to use natural medicine the wrong way
as it is to use medicine the wrong way.